the bow don't sweat now peace well
he done it beautiful Tony gonna burn my
troubles away I'm going
we've talked a lot about mods before but
just like when you're trying to get rid
of spiders you get one and then another
10 pop up
however unlike spiders we love mods and
we would be happy to cohabit with them
if we had to
we've picked another five of our
favorite mods in case you think your
game needs sprucing up remember to use
the hashtag GS fallout to send us
questions and submissions on Twitter and
let us know in the comments below if
you've seen any excellent mods Blood is
fantastic it's what keeps us alive keeps
a heart beating keeps all our
extremities warm and functional it's
also super fun to look at when it comes
out
looks just like syrup tastes like metal
comes out surprising you fast oh should
I should I be should I be losing this
much this mod makes blood look a bit
better better blood means better battles
realistic gore and making the blood God
very happy these blood decals are higher
resolution bigger longer-lasting and
more varied if you like your blood like
you like your coffee thick gorgeous and
splattered all over the floor then
you'll love this mod it can be a bit of
a pain in the arse to use default
workbench is found in for our four
settlements because there's no real way
to organize search or even understand
the systems without having to look them
up first this mod not only revamps the
crafting interface by giving you
categories and extending the range of
what you can make but it also adds
things like clothing and ammunition
crafting it's not a particularly sexy
mod sure but just like the invention of
shoes and the discovery of fire it's one
of those things we don't realize how
useful it is until you have it hopefully
we'll see this implemented in a future
patch because we can't do this on
console yet but in the meantime mud away
PC children I have come up with a genius
system said the Bethesda developer it is
based on real-life conversations you
know how you only ever reply to things
with neutral sarcastic rude or curious
sentences no I have no idea
said his co-worker sarcastic this mod
fixes Bethesda's really strange dialogue
choices in particular the wheel of
truncated responses how are you supposed
to know whether sarcastic means a gentle
joke or something designed to tear
someone a new one wouldn't it be nice to
know what you are actually about to say
so you can make sure you're not about to
piss off a load of dudes with
guns get this mod and you'll be able to
see each response in full ordered by
number rather than whether or not it's
bakery sarcastic good news it also works
with game pads you know the drill you've
spent hours in your settlement you
finally grown at just the way you want
it everything is in the right place all
the lighting is hooked up and the stairs
actually connect to the floor it's
perfect
and then you wander out into the
wasteland and the first house you
stumble upon looks like it's had the
entire IKEA catalogue to choose from
rather than the jumble of secondhand
furniture you go if the furniture exists
why can't me use it well says this model
you can or you just think sanctuary
Hills could do with a little bit more
greenery this mod has you covered
finally your settlement can actually be
the prettiest place in Boston because
you deserve it grateful or anything but
if we found a free boy on the ground and
it had a rubbish interface we just throw
it right in the bin oh maybe we just get
this mod because that's pretty drastic
the roads and the pit boys maps are very
hard to see so often just looks like
icons floating in the middle of darkness
this mod ramps up the contrast of the
roads pop up like slug trails all over
the place in case you've enjoyed
sticking to the path as much as you
enjoy driving at the speed limit in GTA
the maker of this mod also did a
colorful mile X Mart in which the mile
oaks are all rainbow colors and much
prettier for it so we're pretty sure you
can trust them so those are our top 5
mods for this week if you have any
suggestions for mods you want to see
feature in the show or you want to share
your awesome creations artwork cosplay
anything like that make sure you tweet
at us with the hashtag gs fallout and
now we're going to take a look at this
week's submissions and tweets from the
community our first tweet is from the
Bobby panda and Everman he says I miss
having my hunting rifle on my back it
was a nice little touch that I want back
hash-table GS follow I I agree I that
was one of the things I missed it's nice
to see what weapon you're carrying
around yeah I want to have like samurai
swords on my back make a blank showing
and then stab people
okay gray wasteland ninja next week
comes from palm frond john really needs
to be able to see exactly what my
character is going to say one word does
not convey meaning well funnily enough
there's a mod for that we just featured
this moment so you know if he's watching
this video yeah because his tweet and
he's gonna see that you saw this
so we do here on the fallout show with
problem solvers and the first creation
we have is a nuka-cola rocket bottle by
punish crops we feature this guy before
when you repainted his pip-boy edition
now he's gone 3d printed how do you make
the bottle that's cool yeah he's a 3d
rendered the whole thing printed it
painted it
this guy's talented individuals it's not
real glass though is it well you can't
have everything and it's quite a small
serving of Cola
it's pretty good it means I'd be happy
to feature that in my fallout collection
so shine excellent work our next one is
a Fallout basketball court which is
there's a lot of soft games you can make
in Fallout it requires a lot of time and
a lot of patience and you might have
noticed there's a basketball hoop that
you can actually put in your settlement
yeah that seems to be doing much but I
was talking to a rogue ocean gaming on
Twitter the the chap who submitted this
got a bar and everything he's actually
got a fiver side basketball now and
you've sort of got scoreboards but well
fake fake scoreboard they they do the
trick they yeah I mean because because
fallout is obviously a single-player
game the only way to play with your
friends an idea if you could play horse
I just pass the controller interesting
so I think maybe we should do that in a
future episode
our next submission is a vault one one
one settlement by Ryan C t29
it's basically ryan has made a
settlement side vault 111 cleared it all
out using console commands mods and
everything like that and made it
somewhere nice and clean nice and
livable all his settlers and ice income
fees got is a mess hall there there's
Christmas lights a shared accommodation
it's pretty amazing like how detailed is
managed to get with the old grimy vault
it looks pretty nice I mean you can't do
this on console there's just no too much
stuff like you can't get rid of all the
three radroach bodies yeah your
husband's cool well all the settlers are
now nice and comfortable in their vault
111 suits even rename them to fought 111
residents smart they still do keep that
wasteland grind though so they might
need a shower
but than that that was really cool
creation so the next thing we're gonna
look at is a tale
from from links for 36 on reddit of how
he made the robot Curie for fallen in
love with him and Kate's going to do a
nice dramatic reading for us
I got Curie fairly late in my
playthrough and so a lot of quests that
would have given me reputation with her
were either unavailable or I'd already
completed them however Curie apparently
likes it when you healed dogmeat so I
did the only logical thing and went and
found dogmeat at Sanctuary and shot him
over and over again so I could heal him
while Curie stood by and fell in love
with me for my noble actions I'm the
best that's pretty sad that's one way to
make a robot fall for you that I met my
boyfriend
oh god having dogs did you shoot just
the one over and over again okay we're
gonna chat off off mic but you fall in
love with me Dave don't shoot my dog I
will I will go ballistic anyway that's
all we've got time for this week's
fallout episode thank you for everyone
who submitted tweets and our work and
everything else like that again if you
want to share yours with us use the
hashtag GS fallout you can find me on
twitter at a regular dave you can find
me on twitter at how not to draw and
stay safe out there wastelanders
wake up Java the bow don't sweat now
the government's a beautiful day